your first property deal you did you
said beginning of 2020
that was a no money down deal yeah how
did you structure it
how did you find the rent to rent what
happened give me the give me the detail
yeah so yeah the first deal it was a
company purchase
so uh the people before they had a rents
around portfolio
two rent spreads on that uh and in total
it was 12 rooms
so we first come across that by looking
on right move
on right move this advertising one of
the houses
so i called them and i said listen i'd
like to do a company let agreement on
this
and basically i was like how are you
going to make the margin because
the way that we wanted to do it was
basically how they was doing it but
basically
i pushed through and i said you know i'm
sure we can sort something out
so i went there uh spoke to her and
found out
found out a little bit more about her
situation that she had another rent
rent also in gloucester so
then we understood that she was actually
looking to sell the company so then we
started talking about conversations
of getting the company uh yeah actually
approaching the company
and there was three different ways so
number one was going to get a loan that
filed through was going to get a
investor to actually fund us it as well
that fell through and then the third way
that we ended up doing it was that the
company
we saw structured it as a lease option
agreement so the company
he actually paid for half of the money
and then
the profits that it's making up uh every
month which is like three thousand pound
from those two rental rents
that's currently paying them back as
well so
um yeah that whole duration of that is
like a 16 month lease option agreement
so after the 16 months
we'll have 100 access to the profits
and um yeah there's like four years left
as well on those
um agreements on the management
agreements
so hold on a minute that sounds
extremely confusing
so let me get this right this is a
company
right and that company is operating
two rent to rents they're big properties
what six bed five beds six beds building
six both six bed
so this red to rent company has got
these two six bed
properties great you approach the
company
why would the company not want to
continue running those rent to rent if
they are so profitable why would they
even
entertain having a conversation with you
guys so i think that it was more dance
personal reasons for themselves
what happened what's the story they um
[Music]
well there was two things really they
had they originally started for four
um shareholders i think yeah like four
company directors
yeah um and then it turns out three of
them sort of
went off did their own thing which left
the one of them just to manage the two
houses yeah yeah yeah lesson in that
though
when you're setting up a business with
people i i always advise this you know i
often see like a group of friends that
have a company yeah and it
often fails because two or three of them
don't pull their weight
leave it on the other one and then the
other one gets resentful and then the
company just starts to fall apart
so the problem wasn't with the
properties the problem was with the
structure of the company so it started
putting strain right
yeah and then and then what happened
yeah so
um well what happened i didn't know for
them so they're like
it's there's three of them not pulling
away so one of them did all the work
and then how was that panning out for
them wow they actually had because one
of the properties they were
um went into a company right
um so that they were sort of that sort
of rent income for that property but the
um the second property they
had only had the one tenant in there and
they didn't manage to
fill that property so they were failing
it big time yeah from the minute we
met them and you know was communicating
with them and everything
i think then they had no tenants in and
then they eventually had one tenant in
and from then until we took on the deal
there was
no more tenants in that property so were
they losing money
or breaking even or what i think with
the company they had in the property
the previous the other properties are
right yeah they were breaking even i
think
yeah so there was they was actually
making 500.
it was they were still going over
because that's how much of a margin
there was
on both properties so the properties
were excellent renter rents but they'll
be managed poorly
because of a bad company set up so you
came along and said
let me take on the company yeah we'll
manage it tk lifestyle properties will
do a better job you've been trained
you don't on the academy did you tr but
you said you needed a lease option on
the company so
they wanted some money right yeah that's
right would they not just give you the
company
um no i mean initially they were the the
whole
money up front but literally how much
were they asking for like a big amount
they was asking for 35k wow 35k okay
the initial amount was actually 45k
probably been
uh madison negotiated down to 35k okay
so they're saying
so they're saying to you we've got this
we've got these properties they're great
to reads we're struggling with them if
you want it you could pay us 45 grand
yeah and you negotiated them down to 35
grand yeah but you said you're paying
them
out of the profits of the properties
themselves
and and you'll do that over a 16-month
period yeah on effectively at least
option agreement
that's right okay so very creative and
and you're an accountant by triad yeah
yeah so good
boy um just admin and operations
right but you're kind of people person
numbers guy
you put together that's quite an
attractive offer yeah so from their
perspective they're struggling with it
and they're just like look have the
company we want some money for it but
you can pass in your own time
and you can pay us from the profits from
the properties that you take on
so you took on the properties and how
are those two properties how are they
performing
yeah yeah they're really good literally
uh the 12 rooms
uh 11 of them are filled up right now
right um
but yeah literally the one room that's
not filled up
we're we're waiting to get the right
tenant in there right so they've
recently become
bacon yeah it's been baking for two
weeks now yeah
so those so those two properties you've
had them now for like a year almost
yeah how much profit i know that you're
using the profits to pay you've been
using to pay
um the original company directors but
how much profit are they
making those two properties how much
they're generating yeah so it's 3k
in total so one one and a half k each
for them so it's
five very good margins and have they
been
how have i performed in terms of they've
been pretty full over the last 12 months
yeah yeah even through lockdown yeah
yeah
i don't think we've had any tenants oh
no we had one tenant leaving one
property and it was filled like within a
few days after
and where is that is that in cheltenham
no we've got one of them in
bristol yeah the other one's in
gloucester right
awesome so that was your first deal
yeah yeah how does it feel to secure
that deal on no money down basis
incredible yeah it was big because it
was it was one that was working on for
like quite a long time as well
in the first time we actually spoke to
that person it was it was september
closed in feb so like nearly five months
right
five years work on it so yeah it was
good to
eventually close it